la acción de la copa africana de
naciones se traslada este sábado a garúa
en el norte de camerún con dos partidos
correspondientes al grupo de en primer
lugar nigeria va a buscar ratificar las
buenas sensaciones del debut y sobre
todo lograr una victoria que le permita
clasificarse a los octavos de final
enfrente estará a sudán que viene de
empatar en su estreno y que buscará dar
una gran sorpresa en equipo de las
'super águilas' es dirigido por agustín
guapo en de manera interina dio la mejor
exhibición entre los grandes en la
primera fecha del torneo y quiere
demostrar que está en condiciones de
pelear por el título pese a haber tenido
una preparación caótica ya contar con
varias bajas incluyendo la del delantero
víctor o tsimin en el segundo turno
saldrá a la cancha de egipto un gigante
en problemas el que viene de mostrar una
pálida imagen en su debut precisamente
con caída ante nigeria va a enfrentar a
guinea bissau es necesario que el equipo
de carlos queiróz o se sume de a tres
para no complicarse y para eso necesita
abastecer mejor a su gran figura mohamed
salah quien en un primer partido entró
muy poco en juego en frente de este
equipo de guinea bissau los zorros de
ese país van a contar con
es el producto de un brote de kobe 19
bajas importantes e incluido también su
entrenador ciro can de quien no podrá
estar en el banco de suplentes